President of the United States is now
directly and specifically endorsing and
glorifying political violence meaning
physical violence against people whose
politics you disagree with or who you
identify as your political opponents and
against media and we've been talking
about this physical violence trend or
problem on the right for a long time and
there's this projection that exists on
the right which we've pointed out for a
very long time the right likes to say
the left police is language but the
right actually does a fair share of
language policing themselves the right
likes to say that the left is all about
political correctness but the right
enforces its own extraordinarily toxic
version of political correctness as well
and of course the right likes to say
that the left and an Tifa and
eco-terrorists are so physically violent
but every study confirms time and again
that the overwhelming amount of
political violence physical political
violence is coming from the right you'll
remember that Donald Trump offered to
pay the legal fees of people arrested
for fighting at his rallies during the
presidential campaign I believe he
didn't actually end up doing it but he
was saying it pretty frequently Trump
promises to pay people all the time and
then ever all through we should we
should that it's not about the violence
it's about Trump just doesn't pay people
when he promises to trump and his
attacks on media could very
realistically create real-world violence
using terms like scum about media and in
fact we had a person an American a
us-based journalist named Jamal
Khashoggi killed in Saudi Arabia all as
a result of the stories that he wrote in
The Washington Post and then now he has
sort of gone completely over the line
praising that congressman Greg Jenn
Forte for body slamming a reporter I
don't know if you remember this this
story but when Greg John forté was
running for Congress in Montana he body
slammed a reporter and Trump is now
cheering it at a rally in Montana check
this out but Greg is smart and by the
way never wrestle him you understand
that never
any guy that you do a body slam he's
Micah
yep and then more cheering of the
violence and the crowd just loves it
look at them and I heard about it and we
endorsed Greg very early but I had heard
that he body slammed a reporter
and he was way up and he was way up and
I said oh this was like the day of the
election or just before and I said oh
this is terrible he's gonna lose the
election then I said well wait a minute
I know Montana pretty well I think it
might help him and it they're full are
cheering and Trump is cheering the
physical assault of a reporter so there
are three stories here number one the
projection okay the right painting the
left is violent the overwhelming
majority of the political violence is on
the right number two this has a
real-world impact
Jamal khashoggi more readily more nearby
hostility towards regular reporters
security situations all the time with
CNN reporters for example at Trump
events where they need extra security or
to be escorted out and then the third
story is Trump always more aligned with
authoritarian regimes and the action of
authoritarians France Germany England
Canada increasingly hostile
relationships Turkey Russia North Korea
Saudi Arabia and it cannot be ignored
that the hostility towards media that
Donald Trump is espousing here is
related to the killing of Jamal
khashoggi in Saudi Arabia because he
called for reforms and criticized the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia how dare he do
that
Trump involved there possibly in the
cover-up rather than the investigation
at least as a useful idiot parroting
this possibility of so-called rogue
killers being responsible a journalist
was killed for doing journalism Trump
provides cover to the killers and then
now he praises an elected official who
body-slammed a reporter when he was a
candidate is this sociopathy is this
evil like is this just what being a
genuinely bad person looks like and if
it were just Trump it would be one thing
it would be plenty bad but it would just
be one thing but his followers are
cheering his followers are cheering and
and loving the reference to when a
reporter was body slammed by a
Republican yeah and remember Trump ran
as a law-and-order type he's now the
chief executive of the country and he's
encouraging law breaking it's not like
Gian Forte was under attack by the
reporter got hit with the right hook and
then had to bodyslam the other guy in
self the
no no this was this was all his doing
but what's crazy is they don't even have
to argue it's self-defense like you
would think that if they if there was
going to be some political costs for
body-slamming the reporter they might
even try to say well he was defending
himself you know the reporter was
carrying a knife or he had picked up a
chair in a sort of WWE style attack they
don't even lie about it because they
just don't need to he asked a question
about health care yeah that apparently
triggered Gian Forte so much that he had
to attack the guy anyone this guy is
your congressman and they have the
audacity to complain that Sara Huckabee
Sanders and Stephen Miller can't eat out
in peace because they're being heckled
these people are disgusting and they
have no shame today's episode of the
David Pakman show
made possible in part by zip recruiter
there are job sites that will send you a
lot of the wrong resumes to sort through
or they will make you wait for the
correct candidates to apply to the job
that you are trying to hire for
sometimes quickly that is not smart what
is smart is going to zip recruiter
dot-com slash Pakman to just hire the
right person because zip recruiter
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds the right candidates for you
it's powerful matching technology scans
thousands of resumes identifies people
with the right skills the right
education the right experience for your
job and actively invites them to apply
so you end up with qualified candidates
quickly no sorting through the rung
resumes no waiting for the right people
to apply and that's why zip recruiter is
rated number one by employers in the US
this rating comes from hiring sites on
trust pilot that of more than a thousand
reviews and right now our viewers and
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at recruiter dot-com slash Pakman that
is zip recruiter comm slash PA que ma n
zip recruiter comm slash Pakman it is
the smartest way to hire